first on CBS this morning the head of
the Minneapolis Police Union is
repeating his condemnation of the black
lives matter movement lieutenant Bob
Kroll is president of the police
officers Federation of Minneapolis we
spoke with him yesterday in his first
interview since for fellow officers were
charged in George Floyd's killing we
called the black lives matter movement a
terrorist organization what do you mean
by that well our our governor said it
was an act of domestic terrorism during
the riots and I think viewership anyone
that watched anything occur occur in
Minneapolis and the the following week
can make their own conclusion no but I
want you to respond about why I'm taking
the governor out of the conversation for
a second I want to know why you called
it the black lives matter movement a
terrorist organization when you see
arson taking place windows being broke
Molotov cocktails being thrown the
police being shot at with live gunfire
thrown rocks and bricks at them burning
down a police precinct the riotous
conditions that was a form of domestic
terrorism in my opinion we should point
out that the Minnesota governor that's
Tim waltz did not actually call the
black lives matter organizers domestic
terrorists what he said is that the
protests were being hijacked by domestic
terrorists there's a bit of a difference
there we'll have much more of our
interview with Kroll and other leaders
of the police officers federation of
minneapolis ahead they respond to
comments made by the minneapolis police
chief on 60 minutes on sunday night and
tell us about their first reaction to
the video of George Floyd's death is you
know anything he was joined by three
other officers the interview went on for
quite some time we covered a lot of
ground so there's much to discuss
yeah there is and I think there is a big
difference between calling somebody a
mistic terrorist and saying it's being
hijacked by them exactly